Speaker 1: The David Pakman Show depends on the
support of our audience. Our primary source of
funding is the membership program we have on our
website. Join Pacman dot com. We do an extra show
every day called the bonus show for our members.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Well, okay. I wouldn't call it quite so
bad. It's just an extra show, Alex, but thank you.
You can sign up at join Pacman dot com and
you can use the coupon code. Big voting 22
to get a sizable discount off of the cost of a
membership. Hope to see you on today's bonus show.
Ginni Thomas lawyer says she's just too stressed
out to testify because of what's going on in the
United States today. Yes, it's beyond parody. So
let's back up a little bit. Clarence Thomas is
a Supreme Court justice. Ginni Thomas is the wife
of Clarence Thomas. Ginny Thomas, we now know, was
very much involved in the fake elector scheme of
the 2022 election, trying to send fake electors to
Washington, D.C. to vote for Trump instead of Joe
Biden, despite Joe Biden having won their state.
This includes Arizona. She was heavily involved in
the lead up to the January 6th rally that Donald
Trump did before the riot. Jenny Thomas is a very
involved and this also puts Clarence Thomas in a
potentially compromising position where many
are saying he should really recuse himself
from anything even remotely having to do with the
2020 election. The January six committee now wants
to hear from her and her lawyer says, guys, she's
just too stressed out. And this is only days after
she said she was eager to testify yet again.
Oh, I want to tell my side. Okay. We'll show
up and swear an oath. Oh, I'm too stressed now. I
can't do it. Business Insider reports Ginni Thomas
lawyer tries to get her out of the January six
panel testimony, saying it's been a particularly
stressful time amid all of these Supreme
Court rulings. You've got to be kidding me.
The attorney for Ginni Thomas, the wife
of Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas,
questioned the need for her testimony before the
January six committee and said it had been a,
quote, particularly stressful time. Oh, poor
thing. Amid recent Supreme Court rulings.
The House committee investigating the Capitol
riot requested a voluntary interview with Thomas
earlier this month over her efforts to overturn
the 2020 election. She didn't formally accept
the invitation, but she said two weeks ago
she, quote, can't wait to speak to the panel.
Okay. But in an eight page letter sent on
Tuesday, Thomas's attorney, Mark Paoletta,
wrote he had, quote, serious concerns about
the interview. Asked the committee to, quote,
provide a better justification for why her
testimony would be relevant and added in his
letter. I would also note that this has been a
particularly stressful time as the Thomases have
been subjected to an avalanche of death threats
and other abuse by the unprecedented assault on
the conservative Supreme Court justices and their
families. Oh, guys, it's just too stressful for
her right now. But of course, remember Ginni
Thomas 14 days ago? I can't wait to talk to
the January six committee and will, quote, clear
up misconceptions. It sounds like two weeks ago
she saw the opportunity to testify or it wasn't
even to testify. It was an informal interview
to speak to the January six committee as maybe a
stress reducing thing. I would love to show up.
It would be so good for me to reduce and clear
up misconceptions about my involvement. Cut to
cut to this week. Oh, it's just way too stressful
for her. Way, way, way to start. Stressful? Well,
why not clear up the misconceptions? Maybe the
misconceptions aren't really misconceptions.
Maybe she really was as involved as it's believed
in the attempts to overturn the 2020 election.
Did Clarence Thomas say, Oh, hell no, you can't
do that. That's insane. Did her lawyer say,
you know, if you give this informal interview,
the next step is the committee might say, well,
we need you to testify under oath. And then if
you don't, then they might subpoena you. And
maybe the conversation would reveal additional
information that's bad for Clarence Thomas
guys. She's married to a Supreme Court justice.
She must have known that this all could lead
towards sworn testimony in which you would be
bound to tell the truth. And this is straight
out of the Trump playbook. Remember that
one of the classics of the Trump playbook is
the principle. It was often Trump who would
do it. He would say, Hell yeah, I'll show up,
I'll clear all this up. And it's because Trump
thinks he's smarter than everybody in the room.
Trump thinks he can lie and give his false version
of events, and everybody's going to fall for it.
Nobody's going to realize that the guy is lying.
And then lawyers say, Oh, there is no way you're
showing up in testifying under oath. Remember that
with the Russia probe, this was the thing. Trump
kept saying, I can show up and I'm going to tell
him what's what. And of course, every lawyer said,
Oh, dear God, this guy lies uncontrollably. If he
shows up in lies. That's what others are getting
indicted and charged for and found guilty of.
You can't do that. You tell everyone just how
eager you are to share your information. You
tell everybody how eager you are to clarify.
And then later someone else says, Oh, yeah, no.
Here's the thing. She's really stressed out,
guys. She can't show up. And that's exactly
what happened with Trump in the Russia probe.
And listen, I'm open to seeing. Do these Secret
Service agents testify? Do other aides to high
level Trump staff come in and contradict the
testimony of Cassidy Hutchens and bring them in,
put him under oath, and then we'll keep it.
We'll consider it on an equal playing field.
Otherwise, it's just media nonsense. And the
latest is Ginni Thomas is just too stressed out
to show up and clear up everything. Just you
were wrong about everything we've said about her
and she would love to clear it up, but it's just
too stressful for her right now. Gimme a break.